I'm in the United States,
especially in the west,
generally we have a model of self where
the self is kind of like an avocado,
right?
And we have a pit inside of us.
I'm the pit is ourself,
our essence,
our identity.
It is a thing to which we must above all
be true.
Um,
and of course,
very importantly,
we've see that pit is unique so that
everything we do is we want to show to
reflect that pitch,
reflect that self,
and we want it to be unique in Asia.
The people frequently have a Flexi self,
so it's a different kind of self and it
is a self that's oriented more to duty
then to rights for instance.
And um,
and very importantly it is not,
it does not have,
have a cultural mandate to be different
and to be unique.
People in the east are not all alike,
you know,
so if,
if you looked at my family like,
believe me,
every single person is very,
very different.
And that is true of course,
throughout Asia,
you know,
the difference is not,
how different are we from each other?
The difference is how much significance
do we attach to that difference?
In other words,
do we think it's very important to,
to differentiate ourselves from others?
So if you asked him to other
individuals,
of course they're individuals,
you know,
are they different?
Of course they are different for the
course.
For them it's like,
oh,
of course I'm different.
Why would I make a big deal of that?
Right?
Um,
and they think it is very peculiar that
in the West that we feel that we must,
you know,
differentiate ourselves from others
endlessly.
So one of the ways that we do that,
of course it's through choice.
Choice in the West is very,
very important.
Everyone is always making choices.
And honestly,
Alana,
those choices make us a little anxious.
If you do a study where you are just
sitting in an empty room and you're
making a choice and you come from a more
individualistic culture,
you actually show signs of a little
anxiety.
You know,
every little choice that you make,
even in private because it's,
it's defining who you,
who you are is a little loaded.
They feel like they just choose one name
because it doesn't have this overlay and
that's one of the reasons they feel that
actually we are less,
less free than they are,
you know,
so they think that we're the ones,
we're kind of in this prison where,
you know,
like I say,
every moment we must define ourselves.
Well,
it isn't that awful.
Right.
And,
you know,
of course the way,
the way that we live and we feel that,
uh,
you know,
we want to be freely electing to,
to live the way that we live.
Right.
And so even when we're doing things
like,
um,
taking care of the elderly,
for example,
you know,
we want to feel that we,
that is an extension of our great love
and the nature of our being to be able
to care of the elderly.
Well,
you know,
the other day I was having dinner with
somebody said,
you know,
I just don't feel that and it's just,
it's just very,
very hard,
you know.
So somebody from a more flexi self or
interdependent culture was say,
you know,
it's just your duty,
you know.
And so for them it's like,
you know,
they held their elderly parents,
they just go take care of the elderly
parent because that's their judy.
For them,
this is really liberating.
You know,
you just go do it and you don't expect
there to do expression of yourself,
you know,
this is what people do from their point
of view.
We have made things very,
very hard for ourselves to demand that
you know,
that everything should be an expression
of our inner nature.